he's a con artist mutt who doesn't know
what he's talking about he talks how he
wants to punch people in the face well
I'd like to punch him in the face baby
and chief has been chief I call him when
you say that folks on Fox come after you
I remember the Tonys when he got up
there and cursed a lot of you this guy
is like a gangster
that was actor Robert De Niro and one of
his profanity-laced rants against the
president of course us at Fox News
here's some irony for you De Niro was
hit with a twelve million dollar sexual
harassment and discrimination lawsuit by
his former assistant well anyone can
file a lawsuit that's not everything we
don't make any conclusion about that and
and I'd be the first to tell you that
any Oh anyone can sue but in this case
De Niro's assistant has evidence in the
form of well at least an angry voice
good acting except it's not our question
tonight is Trump just broken the
entertainment industry I mean De Niro
lives in New York is not in Hollywood
but you get my point here to answer that
question actor Robert Davi Robert people
just seem like they're really unhinged
whether it's Alec Baldwin or Chelsea
Handler says she needs therapy you know
that's me she said that and now DeNiro
he can't control themselves well whining
about Fox News and doesn't like to be
criticized all these people go nuts well
thank you for having me Laura you know
it's interesting I think the vitriol
that De Niro's feeling toward Donald
Trump must come from some may be some
real-estate deal in New York years ago
because it's it seems kind of
unjustified in a certain way I mean
since he became president Trump has been
under attack as we all know with this
collusion and it's misplaced anger and
then
said something like that to the rest of
the nation what he said on CNN about FM
you've got 60 million plus people that
now de niro's a great actor great artist
he's revered around the world and for
him to you know say the president is
acting like a gangster when if you
listen to some of the John Gotti
recordings it sounds a little bit like
that and I'm a problem with the you know
it's they have every right to speak out
yes every right to say we don't care
what you say but everybody has every
right to say whatever they want it could
swear that's just a code that's a
country living in free speech but what I
understand is when they're criticized
like oh you can't criticize me I'm a
professional athlete or I'm an actor or
I'm like hey you want to step into the
arena a politics of bubble then step ISM
okay let's let's do it let you come on
the show and and try that nonsense with
someone like me and then we'll have a
real conversation but you hide behind
these puffs interviews with people where
people just you know suck up to you 24/7
and of course they're gonna say anything
they want Staedtler practically you know
worshipping at its feet in that
interview they give them feed lines and
the courage to say that kind of stuff
instead of a confrontation
it's a continued I mean one time I saw
an interview with De Niro he was on the
stage and people weren't really cheering
or applauding he says come on now let's
applaud this and of course it was
bashing Trump it was almost like it was
required to stand up and applaud and
give an ovation to Trump bashing and
there's a bubble in Hollywood there's a
bubble in New York and in the West Coast
that Donald Trump has been inside both
bubbles and he's bursting it from inside
and with that they're sucking oxygen
they're panicking because they can't
catch a breath something is going on
Kirstie Alley the other day just
mentioned something and I think a lot of
people in Hollywood have have been
frustrated with this how many years are
we gonna have of this collusion and now
we have Ukraine and this and that and no
one talks about a shift making stuff up
none of the wise I mean god bless us all
it is anti-trump all the time Robert
love having you on